[Music]
in Rocketplane news submitted by Slick
Rick Elon Musk has announced his new
that's what it was good when you start
saying you um must yeah I was like you
got an eyepatch he does the ruler is he
still alive I think so Elon Musk has
announced his plan he completely
revolutionized the travel induced ride
yes I think it's like New York from here
to New York it's like 30 minutes right
yeah
teleportation yeah teleportation I don't
really give a [ __ ] about that how about
just making from Santa Monica to here
yeah there we go
three seconds yes well he's working on
the Hyperloop to do the San Diego - la
la - like that monorail thing and that's
also in like 30 minutes right yeah how
long from San Diego to here I think it's
an hour what happened to the bullet
changer that just cuts an hour right I
think people voted against it or
something and the Vegas one - San Diego
it takes two hours with no traffic cuz
honestly if it was like 30 minutes from
San Diego to hear iPod me for San Diego
oh just yeah I love the beach like crazy
I'm I'm destined to be by the beach I
know it in everyone think it's just it's
like a mini know why because everyone's
nicer - everyone's like just chill
anyway so yes Elon Musk did announce
that and he also announced that he wants
to get humans to Mars by 2024 soon yeah
but first we'll talk about the rocket so
the rocket which is called bfr AKA big
[ __ ] rocket really yeah I love you
almost there watching Mary yeah we
Miriam thought about it for like I don't
know any before and after picture she
was like a total geek yeah and then now
he's like a pretty handsome guy he is
pretty good-looking Oh was that the
Amazon guy oh no oh you were so good the
big [ __ ] rocket will be 347 feet tall
29 feet wide and have a 150 ton payload
which is five times the amount
of the Falcon Heavy which is company's
current largest vehicle so I'm gonna
show you guys a clip before you do that
okay
entertain my imagination for a minute
this is how I see a [ __ ] rocket
alright
so from LA to New York right a rocket in
my mind goes Shh gonna land right so
there's gonna be all these pieces just
trashed all over the u.s. those are the
people that want to land in San Antonio
or Mississippi nothing say anything
about basics the big [ __ ] rocket no
SpaceX because recently I remember
reading headlines that they they were
able to figure out how to get those
pieces to come back and not be trashed
to be reusable so then that's the idea
for this rocket so I'm gonna show you
guys good videos like the concept video
here this is for passengers yes so it's
pretty much replacing plane because you
could go anywhere in the world
with it like less than an hour that's so
if that drug dealer and you want to get
your product out really far damn damn
I would have our five times ready
what oh it does fall apart in space what
do you mean well it goes home yeah it's
like that tough that's tight
no land like that 39 minutes in Shanghai
I never seen on rocky land that way
before
la de Toronto 24
that's crazy
it just made the world that much smaller
exactly
you know how astronauts have to go
through all that like spinny spinny in
the water all that kind of like
dizziness stuff
yeah the g-force training yeah do you
think we have to do that and get ready
for it or like I think so I'll do
whatever it this is 20,000 miles an hour
17 yeah I think they should get an
anesthesiologist and just put you to
sleep you wake up barf all over you he
didn't mention when he's like projecting
for this to be a reality but he did
mention that cost per seat should be
about the same as a full fare economy in
an aircraft that's crazy are these are
gonna pass out peanuts over the flights
way too short probably too short want to
throw them up yeah dude this is gonna
change
don't wait it's gonna be an economy
class ticket yes
it's 30 minutes to New York mm-hmm this
is gonna change the game to
long-distance relationships - oh yeah
you're not gonna exist anymore like
you're never gonna be able to get away
before they would say I'll beat that
[ __ ] up next week yeah yeah I'll do it
at 30 better yeah you got a senior
that's true I could have visited just
way more often if it takes 30 minutes
just to get to New York or whatever even
Hong Kong dude yeah does even have stops
in between or is it only really far
places
he hasn't even announced a date or
anything or like how like any other
details other than the idea we don't
really know economy ticket that's like
it depends on where you know but it just
sounds like it's affordable yeah it's
under like at the most it's like 2000
during high-traffic season right yeah
could be like the Concorde the the sonic
boom thing with the wing that's like me
I mean that knows that's like that that
one it reduced flight time as well but
the tickets were stupid expensive and
the seats you can't even fit and it was
just like not a comfortable right so I'm
really curious to see how like
passengers would be sitting and just
walking in yeah like how would we go
through all that are you shooting like
this now
because it's a rocket you're like facing
up hahaha
have you tight how are you so buddy it's
like when we went to Japan we went on
that bullet train we never went on a
bullet train before right so we're
anticipating it to go really fast it was
like 100 miles per hour
no it was like 400 smooth as [ __ ] please
don't really fast but I was like like
this like waiting for that [ __ ] it's
just mm-hmm
and we went on the slowest out of all
the bullet trains oh yeah there's even
faster one so this slowly takes off and
slowly builds up to it me I should
gradually so the only thing that he also
announced was a whole mars thing that i
mentioned earlier and so he's saying
that he hopes that by 2022 he will send
at least two cargo ships to mars and
then two years later have humans start
going not that's [ __ ] less than
that's five years yeah I can hate this
guy he's so [ __ ] awesome right
everyone else's tweets as like normal
[ __ ] god dammit got Burchard I like our
egos I'm a send people to Mars next week
any call [ __ ] [ __ ] big [ __ ] rocket
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] this is the size of
the big [ __ ] rocket and this is the
first rocket that they had little
[ __ ] rocket evolution
yeah and then this is how many
passengers candy huh this wasn't a specs
I'm not sure but they did mention
passengers for the Mars trip which I
guess but this is all happening within a
couple years kind of the Mars one yet oh
how about this one but the traveling
intro sign it we don't know yet you know
he's a hurry up he always like excites
us with all this like new [ __ ] but I
think he's a premature ejaculator
I like I'd like to be surprised like
guess what we already have this we've
been working on it don't [ __ ] say
like oh look at these fake-ass pictures
and like it's good this is hard I don't
want to know cause it's foreplay though
why do you want to just go in wrong
coming from you what okay so that that's
how you feel about it but then what are
your thoughts on the fact that you guys
tell people that we're gonna have a
movie and then years later years the
movies just a longtime movie has been
done before yeah it's nothing like but
you yeah you keep going it's like if I
guess what you know what we're gonna
teleport so you're telling in 30 years
it's like I might not [ __ ] survive
that long so you're telling our fence
the movies gonna be basic yeah that
we're saying no I'm telling our fans
that a movie is coming within the next
few years
yep so that's the third telling us to
and an exterior is humans are built on
Mars I'm talking about the rocket we
don't know when the rocket is coming
you said Tommy 2200 the credit for the
Mars think it's a big accomplishment two
years that's a short that's a short time
yeah but what about that house battery
he's been talking about that [ __ ] was
supposed to come out yeah I need that
[ __ ] came out already
it tested out in Australia I think but
why isn't it here exactly
maybe all I know is David Tesla been
[ __ ] up a lot well it is David too
though yeah he's feeling crashing in
everywhere he got backed up into well
he's pretty stupid he probably Park crew
wasn't supposed to part like way nicer
freely exit yeah his Instagram he said
that salt shaker
he said Mars city of opposite of Earth
dawn and dusk sky are blue on Mars and
day sky is red whoa
how does he know has he been to Mars I
mean they have Rovers there I know I
just want to hear that he's been on Mars
so he also said that he wants to create
a base on the moon oh he was like you
know it's 2017 why are humans not going
to the moon by now cuz there's no oxygen
fo why are we so [ __ ] into leaving
this planet there's the [ __ ] ocean
that we need to [ __ ] explore Elon Musk
because he's a billionaire he's [ __ ]
that's how this place always talking
about the ocean and like can we please
explore that [ __ ] in rich people know
something we don't
maybe they're like [ __ ] this plan is
going to show we got to find a way out
true maybe that's true but I still want
to know what the [ __ ] down there
Atlantis you know and then the big-ass
[ __ ] octopuses giant squid the squids
I don't know man this guy's crazy his
world of reality and possibilities is
very different from mine we're peasants
dude I don't even think I'm a peasant I
just think I'm a cockroach compared to
Elon Musk Elon Musk is like a alien
that's like he already understands how
to build spaceships and all that [ __ ]
for him that's like building a tricycle
yeah and I'm just trying to figure out
how cars work dude I'm trying to figure
out IKEA furniture this is the four that
like if you like hamburgers he's like
your Chinese friend I ordered everything
on the menu
oh good but you're just like I'll just
get french fries and he's the one oh let
me get that [ __ ] oyster ostrich
[ __ ] spread cook in the back yeah
he's a sous chef is brains too crazy I
know but this whole announcement thing
got me hella excited for the future yeah
what panties for sure I can't wait not
me Philippe we're still alive by the
time we see that happen yeah of course
we'll be I love long flights
I don't know bye you guys I'm old school
all right you take your long see we'll
be in Australia in 30 minutes he'll be
there in 17 hours who binge-watched the
[ __ ] whole episode and I mean host
season of house of cards we were in
koala pouches ain't it yeah we could
probably buy our own planes by that time
this will be dirt cheap all our like
personal drones instead of cars oh you
guys are too materialistic howdy-do
folks thank you so much for watching
don't forget to subscribe to stay up on
their most recent upload and any other
cool content that we put up there and
hit the subscribe button for the last
video click up here
[Music]